So if you are, say, walking down the street and you see this just wildly customized car.
Oh, yeah. Like one of those with the massive spoilers.
Right. Exactly. Like it's got a blinding neon paint job, maybe a heavily lifted suspension and, you know, an exhaust system that sounds like an actual fighter jet taking off.
Oh, I know the exact kind you mean.
Yeah. Well, your first thought usually isn't to assume that the vehicle is fundamentally broken, like it's just built differently.
Right. It's just customized.
Exactly. It's a unique modification tailored specifically to whoever is behind the wheel.
The mere existence of those mods doesn't, you know, trigger a mechanics intervention.
No, of course not. The car runs just fine.
But if you look past all that neon paint and you glance at the dashboard and you see the check engine light glaring that steady, urgent red, well, the situation changes entirely.
That is when you actually have a problem.
Right. The superficial differences completely stop mattering.
That light indicates an internal malfunction. There is actual measurable distress occurring under the hood.
I really love that analogy.
The clinical check engine light is honestly the perfect metaphor for the complex medical framework we are examining in today's deep dive.
It really is, isn't it? Because today we're looking at some very specific source material.
We are because, you know, having a unique mind or a nonstandard body or even a highly atypical set of human interests, it does not inherently mean anything is broken.
Right. It doesn't mean the check engine light is on.
Exactly. In modern clinical psychology, the diagnostic alarm bells are essentially calibrated to ignore mere differences.
They are wired to only flash red when there is tangible, clinically significant distress or, you know, a functional malfunction.
And tracing the exact circuitry of that check engine light is the entire mission of this deep dive.
It's a fascinating area to explore, really.
It really is. So for the listener, today we are analyzing a highly specific set of clinical prep notes.
They're from a source called Pass Ready Prep, and they were compiled by an instructor named Keek.
And Keek's notes dive into some of the most misunderstood areas in clinical practice.
Yeah. We are focusing on three incredibly nuanced categories of the human experience today.
We're looking at sexual dysfunctions, gender dysphoria and paraphilic disorders.
Which are heavily tested topics, but also just deeply relevant to how we understand human behavior.
Right. And for anyone listening, even if you are entirely outside the medical field, these prep notes act as this sort of philosophical blueprint.
They really do. They show exactly how the field operates now.
Yeah. They reveal the exact razor thin boundary where the psychiatric community stops observing human diversity
and decides, you know, it actually must intervene to treat a mental disorder.
And the source material establishes a foundational rule for test takers right out of the gate.
Like, precision and a non-pathologizing stance are just non-negotiable here.
A non-pathologizing stance. So basically not treating everything like a disease.
Exactly. Because historically, psychiatry often acted as a sort of moral arbiter, right?
Yeah.
They would pathologize behaviors or identities simply because they deviated from cultural norms.
Like, if it was weird to society, it was a disorder.
Precisely. But Keke's notes highlight a massive evolution in the field.
Clinicians are now rigorously trained to strip away their own societal biases.
Which has to be incredibly difficult to do in practice.
Oh, absolutely.
But they are taught that their sole mandate is to locate suffering and alleviate it.
It is not to enforce a standardized version of normalcy.
So seeing that evolution in practice really requires looking at the actual mechanics of a diagnosis.
And the notes start us off with sexual dysfunctions.
Right. Which covers a pretty wide range of experiences.
Yeah. The past ready notes outline several distinct conditions.
They list erectile disorder, female orgasmic disorder, genito pelvic pain and penetration disorder,
and premature ejaculation.
And this is where that check engine light analogy really comes into play.
Right. Because rather than just taking a patient's initial complaint at face value,
the text introduces two massive diagnostic hurdles that have to be cleared first.
The first one being the requirement of persistence.
Yes. Specifically anchored to a strict six month timeline.
Why six months though?
Well, the six month rule serves as a critical diagnostic filter.
I mean, human physiology is incredibly sensitive to environmental factors.
Right. For sure. Stressed as crazy things to the body.
Exactly. A sudden drop in libido or a physical dysfunction,
it could just be the result of a stressful month at a high pressure job,
or maybe acute grief or even temporary financial anxiety.
So the body is just reacting normally to a bad situation.
Right. The clinical framework recognizes that occasional systemic misfires are just,
you know, part of being a living organism.
We aren't robots.
Exactly. So by mandating a six month duration,
clinicians effectively weed out the temporary blips of human existence.
They're basically waiting to see if the system corrects itself or if the dysfunction is chronic.
That makes total sense. Yeah.
But the second hurdle though,
that seems to be the actual linchpin of the entire assessment.
It really is the core of the diagnosis.
The dysfunction must cause the individual real subjective distress.
Subjective being the key word there.
Right. Which means if a patient experiences a persistent,
say, six month long physical change,
but they are entirely unbothered by it and it causes no friction in their life,
there is literally zero diagnosis to be made.
None at all.
Going back to the car.
It's like the car might not be hitting top speed,
but if the driver is perfectly happy cruising at 20 miles an hour,
the mechanic doesn't touch the engine.
That's exactly it.
But when that subjective distress is present,
the clinical notes mandate a really fascinating process of elimination.
Yeah. The assessment web.
Right. The text requires clinicians to assess a massive web of potential root causes.
They have to investigate whether the origin is physiological,
pharmacological, psychological, or relational.
That is a lot of ground to cover.
It sounds like they have to act like forensic investigators.
They really do.
Because the symptom, say an erectile dysfunction,
is just the glaring red light on the dashboard.
It tells you something is wrong, but not what is wrong.
Exactly. It tells you nothing about the underlying broken wire.
Which means looking at the pathways Keek maps out,
clinicians essentially have to separate the hardware issues
from the software issues.
That is a great way to frame it, hardware versus software.
Right. So if the investigation reveals a medical route,
like maybe early stage cardiovascular disease,
or an undiscovered side effect from a newly prescribed antidepressant,
the clinician's job is actually to step back.
Yes. They must refer the patient out.
They send them to a medical doctor who handles biological mechanics.
Because you cannot talk therapy your way out of a systemic vascular issue.
You really can't.
But conversely, when the diagnostic web points to the software,
like the psychological or relational contributors,
the recommended treatment protocols shift entirely.
So what do they do for software issues?
Well, the text highlights sex therapy and cognitive behavioral therapy, or CBT.
Okay, CBT. How does that work in this context?
So in a scenario where, say, premature ejaculation is driven by deep-seated performance anxiety,
the patient's brain has essentially hijacked their own physiological arousal system.
Oh, wow. So the brain is just overriding the body.
Basically, yeah.
It is triggering a fight-or-flight sympathetic nervous system response
precisely when the parasympathetic system needs to maintain control.
That sounds incredibly frustrating for the patient.
It is. So CBT operates by intercepting that cognitive distortion.
It targets and dismantles the intrusive anxiety loop.
So the physical nervous system can just naturally reset itself.
It is a really striking framework because it reveals that the
clinical target is never just the physical mechanic, right?
It is always the reduction of the distress loop itself.
Always. Alleviating distress is the ultimate goal.
So if physical distress maps to a specific bodily function like that,
it raises a fascinating question for our next topic.
Oh, I know where you're going with this.
Yeah. What happens when the distress is existential?
Like, what happens when the biological hardware is functioning perfectly,
but it fundamentally clashes with the internal software the person is running?
And that brings us directly to gender dysphoria,
which is mapped in the prep notes under the F64 diagnostic codes.
The F64 codes.
Right. And the text defines this precisely as
a marked incongruence between a person's experienced gender
and the gender they were assigned at birth.
And just like the sexual dysfunctions,
we see the immediate application of that strict six-month timeline
to establish persistence, right?
Yes. The six-month rule applies here as well.
Okay. Here is where the source material delivers what I think
is arguably the most profound clinical insight in the entire curriculum.
It is a massive point of clarification.
Right. Cakes notes make it explicitly clear
that being transgender is not a mental disorder.
Let me repeat that because it's so vital.
Being transgender is not a mental disorder.
Yeah. The diagnosis of gender dysphoria
applies exclusively to the distress generated by the incongruence.
The disorder is the dysphoria itself, not the gender identity.
It is a monumental distinction.
It completely separates modern medical science from its historical predecessors.
So to unpack this, if a transgender individual transitions
aligns their life with their experienced gender
and no longer experiences clinically significant distress
regarding that incongruence, what happens?
The diagnosis of gender dysphoria essentially resolves.
Just like that.
The pathology disappears even though the transgender identity remains.
The identity itself is recognized by the medical community
as a natural variation of human development, fully devoid of inherent pathology.
That is huge.
But wait, looking at this absolute requirement for clinically significant distress,
I have to question how a clinician even measures that objectively.
It can be very challenging, especially given societal factors.
Right. Especially in a society that can be deeply hostile to transgender individuals.
I mean, someone might become incredibly adept at masking their distress
simply to survive their daily environment, you know?
Oh, absolutely. Masking is very common.
Does the text give clinicians a mechanism for spotting hidden dysphoria?
Or are they forced to just take a heavily guarded patient's initial word for it?
Well, the diagnostic criteria actually account for the complexity of subjective reporting.
Clinicians are trained to look way beyond a simple, direct admission of pain.
So what are they looking for then?
They assess for functional impairment.
So subtle breakdowns in an individual's social life,
their occupational functioning, or even the presence of severe compensatory behaviors.
Like the distress is leaking out in other ways.
Exactly.
The distress often bleeds into other areas,
presenting as chronic anxiety, depression, or profound dissociation from the physical body.
Wow. So it's not always just a direct, I feel dysphoric, statement.
No, not always.
A skilled clinician's primary task is building a robust therapeutic alliance.
They have to create an environment secure enough that the survival mask can finally drop,
revealing the underlying incongruence.
That requirement for a secure, supportive environment
directly dictates the treatment protocols Keek emphasizes too.
It does. The clinical response has to match that need for safety.
Right, because the text outlines that the mandated clinical response is affirmative care.
Affirmative care is the gold standard here.
The goal is to support the patient's exploration and alleviate the distress,
which often involves social, legal, or medical alignment with their experienced gender.
Yes, and Keek's notes include a severe, heavily emphasized warning for test takers on this topic.
The trap, right?
Treating the gender identity as the problem is a catastrophic clinical failure.
Exactly.
Keek specifically frames this as a trap on the exam.
Any multiple choice answer that suggests the clinician should attempt to reverse,
cure, or challenge the patient's gender identity is fundamentally incorrect.
And that reasoning is rooted in empirical outcomes, right?
It's not just a philosophical stance.
Oh, entirely empirical.
Attempts to change an individual's core gender identity,
which is often referred to as conversion therapy,
have proven to be not only clinically ineffective, but actively harmful.
Harmful how?
It drastically increases the patient's psychological distress and their risk of self-harm.
Affirmative care, however, has a proven track record
of effectively dimming that check engine light.
It reinforces the core philosophy we have seen so far in this deep dive.
Psychiatry has officially removed itself from the business of enforcing moral conformity
and is entirely focused on managing pain.
The goal is simply to stop the engine from overheating.
Right.
They aren't trying to force the unique car into a standard factory mold.
And this exact logic provides the foundation for our final
and probably most highly misunderstood category.
Yes, paraphilic disorders.
So let's get into this.
Paraphilias represent intense and persistent atypical sexual interests.
Right.
Correct.
This includes arousal templates focused on non-human objects,
the suffering or humiliation of oneself or a partner
or children and other non-consenting persons.
But the immediate foundational principle Keek's text establishes
is that the presence of an atypical sexual interest,
a paraphilia, does not automatically equal a mental disorder.
Which surprises a lot of people.
But it's true.
An interest alone is not a pathology.
So to understand how a clinician differentiates a mere interest from an actual disorder,
we need to look at the mechanism of a misfiring survival instinct.
Oh, that's an interesting way to look at it.
Yeah.
Imagine a perfectly normal human drive, right?
Like the thrill of taking a calculated risk in extreme sports.
Right.
Like skydiving or rock climbing.
Exactly.
Adrenaline spikes, dopamine floods the system,
and it is a harmless, sought-after rush.
But if the neurological wires get crossed,
and that risk-seeking drive becomes permanently fused with a severe trauma response,
the system breaks down.
The person can no longer function safely.
Right.
Their internal engine overheats and causes chaos.
So in the clinical realm of paraphilias,
the source material identifies two specific scenarios
where that neurological wire is considered dangerously crossed.
Elevating an interest into a diagnosable disorder.
Right.
So what is the first scenario?
The first scenario mirrors exactly what we have already discussed today.
The interest causes the individual significant personal distress or functional impairment.
So the distress is internal.
Yes.
This means the atypical arousal template has become compulsive to the point of destruction.
It is severely interfering with their ability to maintain employment,
foster healthy romantic relationships, or just operate smoothly in daily life.
Because it becomes debilitating.
Exactly.
That subjective distress turns it into a disorder.
Now, the second scenario shifts the focus entirely outward.
It does.
An interest becomes an automatic clinical disorder if it involves harm
or the tangible risk of harm to others.
Because in the realm of relational psychology and sexual behavior,
the absolute baseline for health is mutual consent.
Exactly.
Consent is the bedrock.
Therefore, any paraphilic interest that inherently relies on non-consenting individuals
immediately triggers a diagnosis.
No questions asked.
The pass-ready text neatly divides specific paraphilias into these two functional categories
to illustrate that boundary for the test takers.
So what falls into the harm and non-consent category?
The categories driven by harm and non-consent include voyeuristic disorder,
exhibitionistic disorder,
fraudoristic disorder, and pedophilic disorder.
Because the core mechanism involves violating the boundaries or safety of another human being.
Right.
The defining psychological feature here is that consent is either completely impossible
to obtain or it is actively and intentionally bypassed by the individual to achieve arousal.
And because of that bypass, the clinical alarm is permanently triggered.
Exactly.
But then we examine the other side of the dividing line.
Right.
The interests that don't inherently violate consent.
The notes list sexual sadism and masochism, along with fetishistic and transvestic behavior.
These are fundamentally different, right?
They are because they do not inherently require the violation of another person.
Individuals can and very often do negotiate and engage in these specific interests
with fully consenting adult partners.
In safe, mutually agreed upon environments.
Exactly.
So because the element of non-consensual harm is removed,
these specific interests are subjected to that distress and impairment test we talked about.
Correct.
So if an individual possesses a fetishistic interest, engages in it exclusively with consenting adults,
and it causes them zero internal anxiety or functional impairment,
what does the clinician do?
The clinician's assessment stops right there.
Really?
You just step back.
They do.
The individual possesses a paraphilia, but they do not possess a paraphilic disorder.
The medical field steps back, acknowledging it as a variation of human sexual diversity.
Keeks notes advise test takers to rigidly lock this concept in.
And honestly, it serves as the ultimate through line for everything we have unpacked today.
It connects all three categories beautifully.
It really does.
Because whether analyzing the mechanical failures and sexual dysfunctions,
the existential misalignment of gender dysphoria, or the complex arousal templates
of paraphilias, the modern clinical framework relies on a stunningly consistent logic.
They apply strict timelines to filter out temporary stress,
and they hinge every single intervention on two unyielding criteria.
Right.
Is it causing the individual debilitating pain, or is it causing harm to someone else?
Understanding the architecture of these prep notes offers a profound shift
in how we interpret mental health classifications.
Yeah, I feel like the general public fundamentally misunderstands the DSM.
Oh, completely.
The Diagnostic and Statistical Manual is frequently misunderstood as a catalog
of societal flaws, or a list of, quote unquote, crazy behaviors.
Right, like a list of everything that makes you weird.
Exactly.
But in reality, it is a highly calibrated tool
designed exclusively to locate and map human suffering.
When you grasp that pathology requires distress,
you stop weaponizing psychiatric labels against people
who simply navigate the world differently.
You stop pointing fingers at the neon paint job
and start asking if the engine is actually running smoothly.
Exactly.
Which leads to a deeply provocative thought
that this entire framework sort of forces us to confront
as we wrap up this deep dive.
Oh, what's that?
Well, if a diagnosis like gender dysphoria,
or the distress-based paraphilic disorders,
relies entirely on the presence of clinically significant distress,
we really have to interrogate the origin of that distress.
That is a very valid point.
Right, like how much of the psychological pain
these individuals experience is inherent to their condition,
and how much is artificially generated by the hostility,
the shame, and the legislative barriers imposed
by the surrounding society.
It's the age-old question of internal versus external origins of suffering.
Exactly.
Because if human culture evolves to a point of total acceptance,
stripping away the stigma of difference entirely,
do the clinical distress markers for some of these conditions
simply vanish on their own?
It forces us to ask whether the car is actually malfunctioning,
or if the road we're forcing it to drive on
is just deliberately filled with destructive potholes.
Right.
It suggests that sometimes the most effective clinical intervention
isn't actually treating the individual,
it's repairing the environment they are forced to inhabit.
Wow.
That is definitely a question worth keeping in mind
the next time you see someone navigating the world
with a completely unique build.
Thank you so much for joining us on this Deep Dive.